اسبوعان تقريبا يفصلان بين تصريحين
اسرائيليين فجرى غضبا داخليا وادانات
خارجيه واسعه بعد دعوه وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
طالب فيها بمحو بلده حوار الفلسطينيه يعني
اعتقد ان قريه حوار بحاجه الى محو اعتقد
ان على دوله اسرائيل ان تفعل ذلك
بتصريحات استفزت داخل الفلسطيني قال فيها
ان الشعب الفلسطيني اختراع لم يتجاوز عمره
100 سنه
لا يوجد فلسطينيون لانه لا يوجد شعب
فلسطيني السلطه الفلسطينيه صارت للتنديد
بتصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي المتتاليه
الرئاسه وصفتها بتزييف للتاريخ ودليل على
عصوريه الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي تنكرها
فيما رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شتيه
استنكر تصريحات
ووصفها بالعنصريه والتحريضيه دليل قاطع
على الفكر الصهيوني العنصر المتطرف الذي
يحكم اطراف الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
ورقم التمديدات الداخليه والخارجيه بتصعيد
غير المبرر لتصريحات سموتريتش العدائيه
يقف رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
موقفا صامتا ولا يضع حد له
امر قد تبرره خبايا المشهد السياسي في
اسرائيل
فنتنياهو كون حكومته من ائتلاف حرج يضم
فيه احزاب اقصى اليمين يخشى ان يؤدي صدامه
مع انهيار ائتلافه وبالتالي حكومته
بالكامل هنا قد تكون اسباب استمرار
تجاوزات رئيس الماليه الاسرائيلي واضحه
فهو الزعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
ونتنياهو لا يرغب في خساره تاييد حزب
النافذ فمحاوله معارضته قد تكلفه خساره
السلطه